bienvenidos continuaremos resolviendo
problemas de movimiento de proyectiles y
este vídeo será especialmente
entretenido porque les enseñaré un juego
que pueden jugar con sus amigos el juego
se llama veamos qué tan alto y tan
rápido puedo lanzar esta pelota y se
sorprenderán de encontrarlo bastante
estimulante vamos a escribir lo que
hemos aprendido hasta el momento el
cambio de la distancia es igual a la
velocidad promedio por el tiempo
acordémonos que eso solo aplica cuando
tenemos una aceleración constante
también sabemos que la velocidad
promedio es igual a la velocidad final
más la velocidad inicial entre dos por
otro lado tenemos que el cambio en
velocidad es igual a la aceleración por
el tiempo y también que este cambio en
velocidad es igual a la velocidad final
menos la velocidad inicial probablemente
ustedes ya sabían esto antes de
encontrarse con estos vídeos pero ahora
veamos las fórmulas que no son tan
obvias o intuitivas y que se pueden
inferir partiendo de estas fórmulas que
acabo de escribir así que si se les
olvidan las pueden deducir es
en instancia es igual a la velocidad
inicial por el tiempo más la aceleración
por el tiempo al cuadrado todo esto
entre 2 además tengo que la velocidad
final al cuadrado es igual a la
velocidad inicial al cuadrado más dos
veces la aceleración por la distancia
usando estas dos fórmulas pueden jugar
mi juego de qué tan alto y qué tan
rápido lanzó la pelota todo lo que
necesitan en su brazo una pelota un
cronómetro y quizá algunos amigos para
jugar como jugamos el juego
tomamos una pelota y la lanzamos hacia
arriba lo más fuerte que podamos y vemos
cuánto tiempo permanece la pelota en el
aire entonces qué datos tenemos bueno
tenemos el tiempo desde el momento en
que la pelota deja su mano y cae al
suelo de nuevo también conocemos la
aceleración la aceleración es igual a
menos 10 metros por segundo al cuadrado
aunque si están apostando dinero en este
juego seguramente querrán hacer sus
cálculos lo más exactos posibles así que
querrán usar el valor real de la
aceleración de la gravedad
de menos 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y acá eso conocemos el cambio
de la distancia al principio no sabemos
qué tan alto ha subido la pelota pero el
cambio en distancia durante todo el
tiempo si lo vamos a saber pues inicia
desde el suelo o bueno casi desde el
suelo asumiendo que ustedes no miden 300
metros de altura así que inicia en el
suelo y termina en el suelo así que el
cambio en distancia durante todo ese
tiempo es igual a cero
delta d es igual a cero esta cantidad es
interesante es una cantidad vectorial
así que la dirección importa si les
preguntara qué tan lejos llegó la pelota
entonces tendría que ver la ruta que
siguió que tan alto llegó etcétera y si
de verdad quieren ser precisos el cambio
en distancia será la altura de su mano
cuando la pelota dejó su mano así que si
ustedes me dieran no sé un metro con 80
centímetros el cambio en distancia sería
de 1.8 metros pero no vamos a hacer esto
aquí pues para mantener siempre la
resolución del problema entonces
conocemos estos datos tiempo
aceleración igual a menos 10 metros por
segundo al cuadrado y el cambio en
distancia que es igual a 0 y queremos
calcular qué tan rápido lance la pelota
ya que con esto probaría qué tan fuerte
soy entonces quiero calcular la
velocidad inicial velocidad inicial es
mi incógnita entonces cuál fórmula de
bolsas bueno primero uso de las formas y
después les enseñaré una manera
divertida más fácil e intuitiva para
calcular pero primero les mostraré que
pueden usar estas fórmulas para
divertirse con sus amigos
despejemos la fórmula para encontrar la
velocidad inicial tenemos que el cambio
en distancia es igual a cero tengo mi
incógnita la velocidad inicial por el
tiempo y aquí tengo la aceleración entre
2 menos 10 entre 12 es menos 5 por el
tiempo al cuadrado si queremos conocer
la velocidad inicial que podemos hacer
esto es interesante porque podemos
factorizar y sacarla t algo genial de
las ecuaciones de física es que se
pueden razonar con lo que conocemos el
mundo real vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación de esta manera sólo para
confundirlos un poco más el tiempo por
la velocidad inicial menos 5 t todo esto
es igual a cero
aquí lo que dice factorizar t y no tuve
que usar una ecuación cuadrática porque
en la ecuación no tenemos el término que
es constante así que tengo esta
expresión t por velocidad inicial menos
5 por t igual a 0 y la quiero resolver
asumiendo que velocidad inicial es un
número positivo yo sé que hay dos
valores de t en los que esta ecuación se
cumple ya sea para ti igual a cero o con
este término de velocidad inicial menos
5 por t
entonces para que esta parte sea 0 lo
que tengo que hacer es igualar mi
velocidad inicial a 5 t si conociéramos
la velocidad entonces podríamos tener
que el tiempo es igual a la velocidad
inicial entre 5
así que hay dos valores de tiempo cuando
el cambio en distancia es cero cuando el
tiempo es cero pues aún no he lanzado la
pelota y un tiempo posterior que es
igual a la velocidad inicial entre 5
esto no es sólo matemáticas casi todo lo
que hacemos en matemáticas tiene su
aplicación en el mundo real así que
resolvimos nuestra ecuación velocidad
inicial es igual a 5 por t así que si
salen con una amigo y lanza en la pelota
hacia arriba más adelante cuando
resolvemos problemas en dos dimensiones
veremos que no importa mucho si si tiene
un ángulo en este lanzamiento porque el
movimiento horizontal y el movimiento
vertical pueden verse como
independientes entre sí la velocidad que
ustedes obtengan al hacer este juego
será solamente el componente del vector
velocidad que se dirige hacia arriba sé
que esto puede confundirlos pero espero
que le encuentran sentido en los
siguientes vídeos cuando veamos vectores
supongamos que lance la pelota hacia
arriba y le tomo 2 segundos en caer al
suelo
podemos usar esta fórmula velocidad
inicial es igual a 5 por t tiempo fueron
2 segundos mi velocidad inicial es igual
a 5 metros por segundo al cuadrado
por dos segundos aquí estoy usando las
unidades para que quede todo mucho más
claro simplificó esto y me queda que mi
velocidad inicial fue de 10 metros por
segundo
si ustedes son tan fuertes que al lanzar
la pelota hacia arriba se queda en el
aire unos diez segundos entonces la
habrán lanzado a 50 metros por segundo
lo que es extremadamente rápido espero
que hayan aprendido este divertido juego
y en el siguiente vídeo veremos cómo
calcular la altura a la que llegó la
pelota nos vemos